well if it isn't Beginning to Look a Lot
Like Christmas Christmas sucks I hate it
[Music]
I'm gonna get out of that Grinch Spirit
apple plus is a new Christmas musical
with everyone's favorite elf and Dead
Guy spirited is a take on the Charles
Dickens classic A Christmas Carol and in
this video we're going to be taking a
deep dive into the story and if it's a
contender for a holiday classic but
before we do make sure to like And
subscribe or my children are getting
lumps of coal for Christmas while the
main story seems to revolve around a man
visited by the Ghost of Christmas Past
present and future spirited is really
about our ability to change in fact the
whole department of spirits runs on the
idea that people can in the movie's
opening scene we meet the latest case
that of Karen blanksy a disgruntled
Scrooge of a woman who hates everyone on
her street but by showing her the error
of her ways the spirits are able to turn
her life around and make her a beloved
member of the community but are there
people who are too far gone as to not be
saved are there some who are
unredeemable that's the main question at
the core of Spirited story with the
successful change of Karen No Doubt aim
given because of its association with
these the spirits begin their work
finding next year's case they'll have a
full year to prepare everything they
need in order to change what they call
their perpetrator but one of the biggest
tasks is choosing the right candidate
they need someone who can cast ripples
meaning when they change that change
will impact hundreds of others but
before we get there we need to meet one
of our main characters the Ghost of
Christmas present I'll just call him
present for now he's held the position
for 46 years and as he strolls through
the Hall of the redeemed a place where
he can see all the people he saved
including Dolly Parton we get what's
called our I want song a song in which
the character sings to us their wants
dreams and aspirations in it present
dreams of buying a house meeting a nice
girl and maybe even kissing one one of
those newfangled modern mouth kisses but
something is holding him back from
achieving this yes he's technically dead
but as part of his retirement plan he'll
be able to go back to Earth and live out
the rest of his life as a mortal so why
is it then that he's too afraid to
retire we'll get to that in a bit the
search for next year's candidate leads
them to a stuck-up Hotel owner whose
ripple effect could change the lives of
the hotel's hundreds of employees but
while staking out their new Target
present finds a candidate far more
thrilling meet clinda Briggs president
of a PR firm that deals in lies fake
scandals and misinformation whereas
present believes people can change Clint
believes they can't have people changed
no that's the good news
people never change he breaks out into a
whole song and dance about how the key
to success is feeding the hate he's a
man who will do anything and everything
to win regardless of the outcome
president pleads to his boss Jacob to
choose Clint as their next Target just
think of the ripple effect changing him
would have on thousands of people for
those of you familiar with that
Christmas Carol you'll know that Jacob
Marley was the name of the spirit who
visits Ebenezer Scrooge to warn him that
he'll be visited by three ghosts Jacob
was Scrooge's longtime business partner
and died seven years prior to the events
of the book Jacob tells everyone that
Clint is a lost cause that he's
unredeemable but present won't give up
besides
you know it's been done before once
barely if you caught this line earlier
in the movie it foreshadows the film's
big reveal that the Ghost of Christmas
present is Ebenezer Scrooge himself he
wants to take Clint Dawn to prove that
an unredeemable like he was can be saved
and he so believes he can change Clint
he threatens to retire if the boss
doesn't let him Jacob relents in their
year of preparation begins in a really
nice quick Montage no less as we catch
up to Clint a year later we see he's the
same old [ __ ] initially declining to
help his own niece Wren when her school
student council presidency of course
Clint's tactics aren't the most Savory
he'll get his Executive Vice President
Kimberly to dig up dirt on Ren's
opponent but this type of
mean-spiritedness isn't what Ren had in
mind when she asked for help as we'll
see later on in the story it'll have
disastrous Ripple effects on others
Kimberly finds that Josh hubbins Ren's
opponent deleted a damning tick tock two
years ago but is she really the type of
person to be destroying kids lives
that's official I'm a terrible
if Kimberly is going to change as a
person she needs to find the courage to
do what is right so already we can see
how multiple characters in this story
are wrapped up into the theme of change
on Christmas Eve Clint's Journey with
the spirits begins first being visited
by Jacob who warns him of the three
spirits and then by the Ghost of
Christmas Past there's just one snag
Christmas Past has a bit of a crush on
Clint and the two do a little bit more
than just make out under the mistletoe
leaving present with doing her task and
taking Clint into the past it's here we
see how Clint's alcoholic and
manipulative mother tricked him into
thinking he was getting a puppy for
Christmas and conversely how caring and
loving his sister Carrie was maybe
that's why she's called Carrie present
had hoped this memory from the past
would make Clint see the key events that
shaped him but Clint fires back saying
his mom's trick was the best Christmas
present ever the solid gold lesson that
people will believe anything if they
want to believe it and that gets at the
core of Clint's character he has to
believe that people can't change because
it gives him an excuse to be the [ __ ]
that he is that's just the way he is he
can't change it say la vie we'll later
see him with Nora the girl who got away
and she says to him I thought that I
could change you and only a fool would
think
that we'll see Clint working as the new
guy at a company where Kimberly also
works and later he'll use his deceitful
tactics in order to impress his boss but
those tactics do the opposite that's not
the way to conduct business and he's
fired eventually hiring Kimberly and
starting his own business Briggs Media
Group which has no qualms with creating
controversy conflict and spreading
disinformation Clint's past also shows
how unkind he is toward his sister
telling her that she isn't ready to be a
mom when she tells the family she's
going to a fertility clinic but the most
stressing scene from Clint's past is one
he runs away from a scene will later see
in its entirety when his dying sister
asks him to be the one to look after her
daughter when she dies instead of
agreeing to it he shuns her his
selfishness is too much this turns out
to be one of his biggest regrets present
calls this memory a kicker one that
needs to be faced in order to affect any
real change while running from his past
Clint escapes into the spirit's
workplace where he finds the file on him
saying unreading aimable in order to win
Clint back present reveals that he too
was once unredeemable that he was once
Ebenezer Scrooge the man A Christmas
Carol was based on if he can change so
can Clint they travel back in time
briefly meeting Judy Dench before
starting an all-out brawl with the
townspeople and they're transported back
to present day here Clint gets to see
how his co-workers truly feel about him
and it's not that great prison even gets
him to visit Nora who lives with a
loving family and after Clint finally
confronts his dying sister in the past
the Ghost of Christmas present's job is
now over Clint still has one more Spirit
to visit him but now it's time for
present to decide if he's going to
retire and he does waking up right
alongside Clint as Immortal New York
City this guy shares once a month
present now has the chance to make a
move on his Crush Kimberly she was
previously able to see him even though
he was a ghost Because deep down present
wanted her to see him falling in love
with Kimberly is part of his journey in
becoming a better man stepping away from
Scrooge and reaffirming his commitment
to change part of the reason he never
retired was that he was so afraid if he
went back to Earth he'd experienced what
he called a scrooge Deja Vu he turned
back into the evil man he once was this
is why changing Clint was so important
to him I thought
if I can change this guy
maybe there's hope for me too bonus
points if you got the man in the elf
costume he looks stupid Clint's visit
from the ghost of Christmas's future
starts off well but quickly takes a dive
Wren wins the school's presidency but
Josh has killed himself as a result of
her posting that video of him Clint's
actions have now rippled negatively to
those around him and he's seeing this
firsthand there's a very brief shot of
him dying at his desk at the age of 93
before he's thrust back into present day
by the Ghost of Christmas future he
knows he doesn't have much time to stop
Ren from posting that video he in prison
make their way to the ice rink were
there too late or at least that's what
they think while they were gone Kimberly
Found the courage to do what was right
and tells Ren not to post the video
present is ecstatic that Clint went out
of his way to stop his niece from
posting that video it really shows that
he has changed but he's wondering why
there isn't a big dance number in
celebration for this Victory that's
because as Clint reiterates people don't
change age change isn't something that
happens like the flip of a switch it
takes time and in a few weeks he'll just
go back to being the same [ __ ] Clint
that he's always been even though
throughout this journey present and
Clint became Bros this experiment was a
failure so present decides to jump in
front of a bus hoping it will take him
back to the spirit world where he can
resume his jaw but Clint pushes him out
of the way to save his life and does his
first truly selfless act he put someone
else before himself this was the final
thing needed for Clint to truly change
and as everyone indulges in a big song
and dance they're thrust back into
reality when Clint is actually hit by
the bus and killed as Jacob says but
you'll sacrifice would have no meaning
if it had no consequence Clint gets to
meet his dead sister who beckons him
toward the light but Clint has a better
idea how about he put his Elite business
skills to the test and become the new
Ghost of Christmas present with present
now a mortal by the name of Roberto it's
a spot that needs to be filled and who
better than Clint and this Chic up comes
with a bunch of new changes they'll be
taking on multiple cases a year and
branching out to include other religions
very inclusive his sister has even
joined in on the job and he's now dating
the Ghost of Christmas Past we see that
some years have passed since Clint goes
on to visit Kimberly and Roberto who now
have two kids that thing Roberto always
dreamed of we also hear that Ren has
gotten into a master's program at
Stanford and Clint even gets Roberto's
help with a particularly difficult file
so it looks like people can really
change Clint now does a job that helps
others Roberto has turned into a family
man without turning back into Scrooge
and Kimberly found the strength to stand
up for what's right bonus points if he
caught the number 8 1843 by Kim and
Roberto's house which is the date A
Christmas Carol was first published but
I want to hear about what you thought of
Spirited will you be revisiting this one
in years to come or will it wind up a
forgotten stocking stuffer let me know
in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thingsstory YT until next time remember
he's like the perfect combination of
blue saline and Seacrest